well this is a spoiler if you haven't
seen the first episode
but i play a teacher named kate this
just
in there's a big secret amongst the
ruling class at constance biller
what was your reaction when you
discovered that the audience would
find out who gossip girl is right away
i thought that was so smart i was like
you can't there's no point in doing it
again and having it be the same thing
they already did that and i thought it
would be fun to watch
these characters try to keep up this
charade
did you miss me i know i've missed you
when did you find out that your
character kate was actually the
ringleader of the constance billard
gossip group
as i'm calling it well josh our
showrunner
we had dinner before any of this started
for him to tell me about the part and he
told me then
and i was immediately sold i wanted to
focus on the teachers and i wanted to
see what would happen
if the teachers sort of tried to regain
control of these sort of like kids that
were out of control
and knowing that they were gossiping
from the top and watching it destroy
them
gossip girl an anonymous instagram
account that
spies on our students when you found out
that the audience was going to discover
who gossip girl
is in the pilot episode what was your
immediate reaction
just a gasp just a full gasp
in the original you didn't find out
until so late um
and in this one you find out right at
the start but um
it's such a great fun parallel that you
have happening with the
teachers who are operating the account
that's the first time i've said that i'm
so excited
and and the kids um so i think it's a
really great
and the writing is just so juicy and fun
um
and so i think it's a really great
little parallel track we get to be on i
thought it was brilliant
yeah i don't think it works any other
way truthfully um
because because of the setup you have in
the
the original to repeat that exact format
i think would ultimately be
disappointing um and so this way the
audience is in on it and then you get to
pick which side you're on i was shocked
that gossip girl was revealed from early
on but it kind of is
incredible i didn't know anything when i
signed on to do this job i knew my
character's name and that's it
so i had no idea until i was reading the
script and
even then i was like i still don't know
all the details so as we were filming i
was finding things out and i was like
all the way through so it was exciting
if i wasn't born into this world
maybe i could write myself into it
there was a very strong reaction when it
was revealed that dan humphrey was
gossip girl in the original series
did that add any pressure to you when
you stepped into this role
well it's such a different thing to you
know
say who it is from the beginning and
then let that be part of the story that
i was not
worried about obviously you know people
love the original
and we are paying homage but they are
i think it's good that they are two
different things sort of but in the same
world
in the first series not only did we not
know who gossiper was we didn't know how
dan was doing it what are the benefits
of the way that you guys have structured
it with this new
show it's just a different approach to
the storytelling you know it was a
it was a mystery in the first season at
the first show
and uh and this show is just a different
approach and so the audience can
focus on other things i guess and see
the see the toll
that being gossip girl can take on
people it allows for actual comfort like
dan alone would have been boring to
watch him for 121 episodes just sit
there typing
they actually get to talk and they get
to debate whether this is a good idea
about it
some tips they get in future episodes
they really have to some of them
disagree and there's like battles over
it so i think that adds like a whole new
layer
i love the fact that aesthetically you
do remind me of kristen bell just a
little bit
all right not bad i'll take it
who is of course the voice of gossip
girl when you found out that kristen was
still going to be voicing
you what was your reaction
i mean thank god iconic voice over can
you imagine if suddenly it was just like
hey upper east side like any other voice
would be like ah
[Music]
xoxo